- How does it feel to be the vet?
- Man, it's crazy cuz—
I don't think
I haven't talked about this yet—
but it's crazy because, like, whenever music—
like, we listen to music at practice
and even when we in our layup lines in a game,
and it be certain songs that come on
and I'll always ask the guys, like,
"You know who this is?"
They be like, "I never heard this song
in my life," and it could be like a Mary J.
Blige song or something.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It could be a song from 2005, and they have no clue.
- Like, I was just born.
- Yeah.
And it's like, "I was born in 2001,"
and it's like, "Oh, my God."
But at the same time,
you know, it's enjoyable
cuz you learn so much from 'em,
and they teach you so much
in the same token, and once you, like,
accept that, it's fun.
You know, I think one of the guys one day
in practice was like, "Man, you're the only
person on the team born in the '80s.
What does it feel like?" And I'm like,
"I'm born in '89. I'm only 32."
You know what I mean? It's just crazy
to have that back and forth.
And we have fun with it.
So it's definitely cool
just to, just to have that
because I learn so much
from those guys as well.
- Yeah.
Born in the '80s. In '89.
That's crazy.
- And what music they tried to put you on? Like,
NBA YoungBoy or somethin'?
- Everything. You name it. It be some people.
But, but even that.
I listen to it. Like, "Who hot right now?"
I listen to it
just so I could be on the same page
as them as well, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So it'd be cool.
- So when did you realize you were the vet?
Was it when they were like, "'89"?
- Yeah, I think it was like training camp.
It was, it was some somewhere around there.
I think we was listening to, like,
50 Cent "Get Rich or Die Tryin'."
And somebody was like, "Yeah,
I was like one years old or two years old."
And I was like, I remember
buying that CD, you know what I mean?
- That was all anybody cared about.
- Yeah.
I remember going to the store buying that.
And that was the moment.
That was my first moment.
I was like,
it's going to be a long year.
- Oh, yeah. You got to get them
on all that stuff.
They probably haven't heard
even like old Wayne.
It's so much. I asked them about Jay-Z.
They was like, "Yeah, I heard about two or
three Jay-Z songs." And I'm like,
I feel offended.
You know? I feel offended.
- Yeah.
Oh, no. My gosh, no.
Then you have some teaching to do. Cuz this is real life lessons.
- I do. I do. In their credit,
they, they listen.
You know, whatever
it is. Not even just music.
Just anything in general. Even with movies.
Like, I do the same thing with movies.
Have you seen this movie, this movie?
And a lot of them—like, it was one guy.
I'll say his name: Patrick Williams.
I made a reference.
One game we was playing,
I made a reference
from "300," the movie "300,"
and he didn't get it.
I was like, "You know what '300' is?"
He said, "No." I said, "It's a movie." He said, "What?"
He said, "Man, I'mma go home
and watch it tonight." So he went home.
Watched it. Called me after the movie and said,
"Oh, my God, the movie was amazing.
You got another movie for me?"
You know what I mean?
- Oh, that's great.
What did you say, like,
"This is Sparta"?
- Yeah. It was crazy. It was great. But
he went to go watch it and he, you know, but—
- That's great.